- Okay, well in Rebecca's first slide
she presented what I was planning to say
which the issues that we
have are diverse locations,
heterogeneous data and
lack of software tools.
But since I have half an
hour I'll say it again so.
And first of all by background,
I wouldn't say I'm a
trained computer scientist
but we can get into that.
But I'm a computer scientist
and my view of computer
science is we are tool makers
and so my goal here is like
what tools do you need.
I think Rebecca referenced you know
continually looking for available tools.
No no no, go out and
specify the tools you need
and that's what we live
for is new problems.
And I also want to make the point
about machine vision, machine learning.
Machines do not see.
Machines do not learn.
People do and we're making tools
to extend what people can see
and extend what people can learn.
And what I wanted to talk about is what
I mean there's all this great promise,
I mean you're reading all the
stuff that AI and so forth
is gonna make happen.
Like what what's standing in the way?
In my view is a lack of data.
Particularly, some kinds
of data not quantity
and the lack of tools.
So, I just wanted to
present a few thoughts
along these lines
and I thought I'd start by
ripping from today's headlines.
One long-term project that
I work on fits and starts
is learning about stone weathering
from the point of view
of computer graphics,
how to make realistic models.
And from the point of
view of conservation,
what are the mechanisms?
How can we avoid it?
And so one thought for
many years is you know
we can get pictures and
scans of objects today
and these are you know
sculptures from Notre Dame
and we can see all of the
stone loss that there is
and we can estimate the
shapes and so forth of these.
And we can learn something
about the stone weathering process
by looking at historic
photos of the same things,
monuments of this sort people
have been taking photos of
but it turns out to be
really difficult to get
photos and reliable photos
even though there should be collections.
We can see from the ones we find
that there's been tremendous loss.
This is an image from a
postcard that was for sale.
So, unless I wanted to
cough up the money to buy it
I have no idea where this was taken
and when it was taken,
useful pieces of data
that you need if we wanna
conduct this kind of study.
This one's really weird.
It's from a poster that Walmart's selling
that is based on an old postcard.
So, it really have lost
where it came from.
But what's interesting is
there's not as much loss here.
So, like where on the building is this?
Why is there less loss?
And then like aha!
Here I have a picture that is
from the Yale visual collection.
I must have all the data about that.
I can finally know like
where was this taken,
when was it taken.
Well, it probably wasn't taken
in the published created
date of 1220 to 1240.
So, I don't know you know
if there's no information
on the postcard.
If this was what was on the reverse
or if somebody just assumed
that when people looking
through the visual collection
they were interested in the Cathedral
rather than stone weathering
so all the sort of missing data
that either wasn't entered
or if somebody had it
now can't enter right now
because this is a fixed asset.
To a more successful project
from a colleague in France
who's studied Notre Dame a great deal.
He has studied these kings in front
which of course and the theme of
we've been losing Notre
Dame for a long time
these are not the original kings.
The original kings were
removed and beheaded in the,
not kidding, they they took down the kings
the stone sculptures of
the kings from Notre Dame
and publicly beheaded them
in the French Revolution
and only in 1977 the heads were found
in the back of somebody's house.
Anyway, so what he did
was studied the heads
and and the remains in
the in the Cathedral
which they have also 3D scanned.
There's been a lot of news
media about the guy at Vassar
and in Assassin's Creed
and other people who've
but you know obviously
the French have also.
Anyway, he examined remnants
of colors on the heads
and on the structure.
So, bringing together this theme
of having to bring
together lots of sources
just like you have lots of sources.
You have this purple flower
but there's all this stuff
you've got to bring together.
And he also brought together imagery
of how the light changes on the front
of the cathedral at sunset.
And did some hypotheses
of what the cathedral
actually looked like in medieval times.
So, the point here being
you know that the learning
requires assembling
heterogeneous data sets
from many locations.
So, with those themes I
just wanted to talk about
you know three aspects here using 3D, 2D
and organizing collections.
And I realized I don't have the time here
so would you do this, okay.
Okay so, and in 3D, I mean so for you know
as far as computer vision for 30 years
probably you say 40,
we've had all this research
on how to do active scanning
and and photogrammetry.
And you know these are
projects I've been involved in
and of course there's been
thousands and thousands
all over the world in capturing
3D of cultural heritag
and natural history collections.
And these are good for
some individual studies.
Like these are studies of
one of Michelangelo's Pietàs.
How was it meant to be viewed?
What did it look like when Michelangelo
broke it apart before it was repaired?
These are from the
Egyptian Museum in Cairo.
How are these objects used?
And here from a that we did at Yale
a special exhibit that brought together
many busts of the poet of Alexander Pope
by the same artist Roubilliac
scanning out these to compare
how the representation changed over time.
I should say the Smithsonian
has spectacular 3D scans
and particularly I was taken by this one.
This is enormously technically difficult
must have been to challenge
and incredibly informative
it's the the inside of Apollo 11
which you know I hopefully
everybody will visit this year
and on the anniversary.
And it's got great data about it
including this little nugget
about astronaut graffiti
that I wish they said more about.
I'd like like buzzes what what did,
what do you mean astronaut graffiti?
So, also I went yes there was a later talk
is activating an artwork at the Hirshhorn.
I don't know if people at the Hirshhorn
realized that this sculptor by Ferren
inspired a graduate
student named Cindy Gorl
to start a whole line of
computer graphics research for
well that goes on today in a forum
in so called global illumination.
And this is the Hirshhorns
official picture of it
which is pretty good
but you know she had this
one taken to emphasize
this lighting effect
that was the inspiration
that and that so there was a model built
to show this is in 1980 or so
how well we could've simulated
the lighting on this.
And by the end of the eighties
the improvements in lighting algorithms
so another modeling little anecdote
that's associated with the
work at the Smithsonian.
Anyway so there's a lot
of examples of scanning.
I mean like thousands and thousands
of scanning for documentation,
scanning for public communication
but not that much what
have we really learned?
What kind of analysis that we
do that gives us new insights
into the past from these.
So, a group of us got together to sort
of review the literature and find out
particularly with respect to geometry,
that's 3D scanning's about,
what have people actually learned?
And we developed a taxonomy for this
as far as numbers of
objects, scale of objects,
types of application.
I won't bore you with the whole thing
but most of it is either
improving legibility
or doing restoration is what
people have done so far.
So, making so tablets, caneiform
and so forth easier to read.
Reassembling broken pieces,
this is from Benedict Browns work when
back when he was at Princeton
but putting together
in this case Frescoes.
There's another case
of Irish tax documents
that were damaged in
the fire and that were
we have scanned with photogrammetry
so that they can be
digitally flattened and read.
This is from University of Kentucky
where they do CAT scan
and volumetric scanning
of fragile documents so
that you can virtually
unroll and read them.
And then there's a lot
of projects which barrel
from fairly standard engineering
and other aerial survey techniques
to do things like monitoring
of historic structures
or in this case the same sort of thing
you might do for like crop
management or enemy surveillance
using aerial data to
understand usage patterns.
So, a lot of work that involves
basically a single object.
We haven't seen much with collections.
This is a little bit of work on that line,
we're looking at sets of coins
and finding the same
figure across several coins
that were found.
This is another studying the faces
on the Banyan temple in Cambodia
with the goal immediately,
the immediate goal of
trying to do restorations.
This is one true collection study
where these are figures
3D scanned at the Louvre
to try to determine provenance
for pieces that you know
that the their origins aren't known.
And this is a study of
a smaller collection
of busts of Augustus that
were done to try to find
the relationship of when when the busts
were done and by whom.
But overall in our whole survey taxonomy
the collection analysis which
it's just like the big thing
we can do but you know
to do things at scale,
it's a very empty space right now.
So, what is the problem?
Why aren't we doing more
about bringing objects
from different museums together
and doing these collection analysis?
And I think there's two
things that we have a lot of
very small collections that
are scattered geographically
and they are often lacking contextual data
that would make them useful.
I mean this virtual curation
lab which shows up on Sketchfab
and if you're not like sort
of a computer game builder
you probably don't use this site much
but it's where people park
a lot of computer models
because you can.
And it takes a lot of
effort to build this site
that this site Virginia
Commonwealth University
but the models they are from the most part
they are simplified from what
they were originally scanned
because you know just so that
they can be displayable at home
and there's very little contextual data.
And it's it's kind of a
smattering of stuff from all over.
It's not apples to apples kinds of studies
that we want to do.
CyArk which for many years has
been going around the world
doing large-scale scanning of structures
has made all of their data open now.
So, there's dozens and dozens of sites
ranging from huts in
Antarctica to cathedrals
to Cape Canaveral.
So, a lot of diverse places and there's no
lack of quantity of data,
there's gigabytes and
gigabytes and gigabytes.
But you know it's still like
it's not clear.
How can we make use of this?
What do we need?
Is it just managing the sheer volume?
I think we also need contextual
data that goes with it
to understand what we're trying to study,
what questions we're answering.
Just shifting then from
3D to 2D where obviously
there's been a lot more success
because it's one less D.
So, like for example we've had work here
in studying medieval manuscripts
where a lot of work has been you know
it's the same thing
there's many manuscripts
in many different places
so viewers have been built
that can take you know
and standard representations
so that you can take the manuscript pages
from many different sources
and read and compare them.
This is work from mainly from Stanford
in collaboration with Yale.
On our side we did some various test cases
to illustrate studying
large quantities of pages,
both their layout and
their spectral reflectance.
The layout is of interest to
identify things ahead of time
sort of adding data to things
so that's subsequently when
people wanna ask questions
it's easy to access the results.
And so it's layout not
so much the the words,
I mean these are from Books of Ours.
I mean they're prayer books,
everybody knows what they said.
That was kind of the point of them.
But what's interesting
is the different ways
that they are laid out and
spotting things like these.
I don't have a arrow either here.
These little bars that
indicate that this is poetry
as opposed to the the main text.
So, we did a lot of work you
know consistently identifying
layout across and the
challenges in these manuscripts
being lots of damage and things missing
and variety of that sort of thing.
We also did a study of the
apparent color of pigments
to understand changes that may indicate
things being made by different
people in different places.
We did this doing hyperspectral imaging,
I won't go into,
as opposed to regular RGB cameras.
And what was interesting
there's like, oh great!
These things look
different and now not only
do they look different
I have different plots
that are associated with them
and it's still like and so what.
So, is that a significant difference
or not a significant difference?
So, we go on with the
analysis to do things like
go through thousands of
pages and cluster the colors
to count the colors and then see
what is the spectral
variation within pages
to understand what's a normal distribution
of color variations as
opposed to something that's
indicates some sort of change
in authorship or manufacturer.
Another sort of long-term
thing that's bugged me,
I haven't made much progress on,
is you know like the
Google arts and culture
they have thousands and thousands
of high-resolution images.
Like what can we do with them?
What is anybody doing with them?
What is, so one thing is
studying crack patterns
in the paintings to understand
where the cracks came from,
what can we do about them
and if you're lucky and and
on Rembrandt's face or his hat
you have light paint, you
can you can sort of see them.
Although even here
extracting them reliably
with image processing is difficult
and so I've never really
had had various students
start on this and get frustrated.
A brilliant idea that
Lukasz brought us who,
not him, who recently was at the Yale IPCH
and is now running a an
analysis lab in Poland
working with the Yale
Center for British Art
is this idea of using x-rays of the images
rather than just trying to
see the cracks on the images.
So there's an x-ray and you
have to see it close-up.
Okay, the cracks are harder to see
but there's a lot less in the way of them
as far as dark paint, light paint.
So, we have a chance to extract
the cracks from the X ray
and then learn using deep learning
the relationship between those cracks
and the appearance of the paintings.
So, that then once we learned that
we can probably at least to some extent
detect cracks in paintings
that we don't have the x-rays for.
It's not a slam-dunk,
there's a lot of work to do
but it's it's a great idea
that we'll be pursuing.
On the last topic I wanted to touch on
which it was already mentioned
is this problem of heterogeneous data.
You've got all sorts of information
and this is similar to I think
the last couple of projects
you were talking about
so I think we may have
some overlap in tools
we might want to develop.
This is Elihu Rubin from
the School of Architecture
has developed this over many years
through a course he teaches
where students document details
of buildings in New Haven.
The idea is like history's not just
the great persons, the famous buildings
but it's our communities,
it's where we live and our
where we live is is New Haven.
So, documenting the individual
buildings in New Haven.
This is something that
Sima Octa who's here
has been working on as
well as as Benedict.
So, in this archive each
students responsible
for finding as much as they can.
That includes maps from the library.
It includes scans of permit applications
for changes in the building,
lists of who occupied it through time,
just every every little
you know scrap of paper
associated with transactions,
historic photos, stories, social history
so that we're getting this
database of New Haven.
So, then the question is,
now we're getting this great
heterogeneous database,
what kind of studies can we do?
And what tools would
be needed to go across
this corpus of images and texts?
So, that's what I wanted to bring up
was sort of these ideas
like why aren't we using 3D?
We need context.
Where did the data come from?
And more things like you know,
what was the data, the
postcard and so forth?
And 2D this enhancing the
data with new correlations
from labeled samples
and just our new tools
for learning from heterogeneous data.
So, thank you.
(audience applauds)